you
hello welcome from the Royal Swedish
Academy of Sciences where we've just
discovered who's received the 2009 nobel
prize in chemistry joining me to discuss
this prize is Professor gonna von haina
the chairman of the prize committee in
chemistry professor von haina thank you
very much for joining us straight up the
announcement could we begin by you
revealing who has been awarded the 2009
nobel prize in chemistry so the three
laureates are Venki Ramakrishnan from
the UK Tom Stites from yale university
in the States and odda Jonah from the
Weitzman Institute of Science in Israel
and what do they receive the prize for
so they receive the price for their
studies on the structure and function of
the ribosome and so anyone who's not
familiar with what a ribosome is can you
explain why it's important and wise
importance no structure and function so
our bodies are you know the molecules
that make our bodies work or the
proteins somehow the body has to make
proteins and the blueprints for the
proteins are stored in the genetic
material in DNA it then when a
particular protein is to be made little
piece of DNA is copied into something
called a messenger RNA and finally a
ribosome and now we get to the price a
ribosome reads off this mRNA molecule
and according to the instructions
carried by the mRNA molecule the
ribosome puts strings together amino
acids into a specific sequence that will
then make that particular protein so
ribosomes are absolutely essential to
the life of the cell and it's the only
way that cells can make proteins
and so by interviewing a structure
understanding its function but what we
hope to learn so first of all of course
it's it's a deep scientific question is
how does the ribosome work this very
complex machine it's a big molecular
machine and it has very intricate
workings and of course there is this
urge on the on the part of the some of
the scientists is to understand how
these machines work like the ribosome of
course there are also more applied
aspects of this knowledge which has been
gained by these studies and in the case
of the ribosome in particular it deals
with antibiotics and antibiotic
resistance and the possibility to
develop new antibiotics and we'll talk a
bit about the antibiotics antibiotic
resistance bit later but could you tell
us a bit about what tools and techniques
that real already used to uncover the
structure and punch of the ribosome so
they mainly use the technique called
x-ray crystallography which is a way to
determine with very high precision and
resolution what molecules look like and
the ribosome after all is a molecule
it's an extremely complex one so it's a
very difficult problem to solve the
structure to understand how the atoms
are arranged in the ribosome but they
these real Orient's of actually solve
that problem now x-ray crystallography
you make what you basically what you do
is your purify ribosomes which in itself
isn't is an accomplishment then you have
to coax these ribosomes to form crystals
you know like a salt crystal but a
ribosomal crystal is much more difficult
to make an assault crystal and finally
you take your ribosome crystal and you
shine x rays onto it these x-rays will
scatter from the ribosomes in the
crystal and from the scattering pattern
you can if you're good enough and lucky
enough you can calculate what the actual
structure of the ribosome is and so how
difficult a task was it to be able to
get x-ray images of ribosomes so this
was a very difficult task it took more
than 20 years the first problem was
since I said was to to be able to even
to make crystals and all day on earth is
the pioneer in this field she made the
first for a long time she was alone and
she made the first useful crystals
ribosomes after which Tom Stites and
Venki Ramakrishnan came in and and also
in parallel without a univ started to
actually solve the structures on the
ribosome and so once the structure of
the ribosome have been identified then
then scientists try to look at how it
functions and this is also involves the
work of three lawyers could you discuss
that more please yes oh so from these
structures that the three laureates and
a few other people but mainly the
through laureates have produced we have
now learned how how the ribosome can be
so precise in selecting amino acids to
be strung together into proteins so it's
a problem accuracy how can it be so
accurate and we have also learned how
the actual stringing together works how
does it work from a chemical point of
view when one of me main mass it is
tagged on to a growing chain of amino
acids to make the protein and what would
the key discoveries involved in
understanding that function so both
these discoveries were again based on
very accurate structure structures of
the ribosome in various functional
states so it's not enough just to take
one ribosome and make it one crystal and
you get the whole answer but you have to
make very different preparations with
ribosomes bound to other small molecules
or other molecules that take part in the
process and only by studying these
complexes can you then hope to learn
something more about the function and
this is precisely what these laureates
have done over the past few five or ten
years and specifically what what did
they boldly the achievements that the
laureus made in terms of understanding
so so what they have shown us is number
one how can the ribosome be so accurate
so we now understand this on a molecular
level we have how this works number two
we understand how how the actual
synthesis of the protein is carried out
by the ribosome and we also understand
actually a few other aspects of the
whole process which or which you also
have come out of this work but maybe to
going too far to start describing these
in detail and so that understanding the
structure and function tells us about
how how the ribosomes create the
proteins that sustain life but also it's
given us insights and how to save lives
with with the way the antibiotics work
could you discuss a little bit about the
the how antibiotics function and how
they the achievement from the laureates
have helped us to create better
treatments yes so so antibiotics of
course are small molecules generally
that disturbed one or other function of
a bacterial cell and kills the bacterium
it turns out that about half of all the
known antibiotics actually have the
ribosome the bacterial ribosome as a
target so they you know they stopped it
dead in there in its tracks basically up
to the point when we started to get
these structures from the laureates
nobody really understood how these
antibiotics could damage the ribosome
the bacterial ribosome whether whether
work number one we understand how this
right how these different antibiotics
work why are they toxic to the bacterium
but what moreover we also now have a
possibility to look to take this
knowledge and use it to design new
antibiotics that you know may help us
conquer or at least push forward the
resistance problem in a bacterial
develop resistance to various
antibiotics
so if I can sort of move towards the
prize itself as you as you implied this
this research has taken decades and its
answer some questions there's still some
questions to answer of course when when
deciding the price you go to these
people was there any recent developments
or recent discoveries that made it a
more compelling case to select this
prize this year so the main break
through here from the three laureates
was in the year 2000 2001 when the first
really good structures were published
but in the in the interim they mostly
these three laureates but also some
other people have been able to make
these different complexes that have
illuminated various aspects of the
function of the ribosome so there is so
they have continued to contribute up
till the present time action and they
still are but there is a number of very
important steps in the interim that that
have also contributed here then and that
were absolutely essential for four and
for us to be able to award this price
and one thing you mentioned briefly
earlier was the contributions of other
peoples have failed and you know
sometimes when you when you're selecting
a prize they did the laureates are very
easy to pick and sometimes they're there
they're a bit more difficult because
there's so many key players in the field
what was it like this time was it an
easy straightforward decision to make or
what did it require discussion well it's
never easy I can tell you that it's
never easy even if it seems like it but
so clearly this price is surprised that
has been discussed for years in the
committee and we've been through every
possible us aspect of it we think and in
the end you know we come to a decision
it's never an easy decision but we make
a decision and so what they did the
criteria for the selection of these work
could you sort of summarize what you why
you think these are the key achievements
and understanding structure and function
of the ribosome well to go back to what
I said before these are the three people
three key people who have made it made
the determination of ribosome structures
possible and they have also pushed the
analysis such that they have uncovered
he's very important functional aspects
of how the ribosome actually
works so it's from this point of view it
was fairly straightforward decision and
have you spoken to laureates at all yes
we have we call them of course as we
always do and we managed to reach all
three of them and well it's it's it's
always interesting to have these
conversations with people who are woken
up in you know early morning hours one
was Thomas lights was on his way to the
gym and he had I think he had to forget
about the gym for this is this today but
just will one day perhaps and it's worth
noting a course that ad oneth becomes
the fourth woman laureate in chemistry
which is which is which is a nice
achievement isn't it yes it's 45 years
since there was a woman wonder chemistry
price before well professor von haina
thank you very much for discussing this
with us for more information on the
Nobel Prize in Chemistry please visit
Nobel Prize dog where you can see the
announcements and will soon be able to
see exclusive interviews with the new
laureates that's it for now for this
live webcast but join us tomorrow where
we'll discover he'll be awarded the 2009
nobel prize in literature the
announcements expected at one p.m.
central european time but for now it's
goodbye from all of us at Nobel Prize
org
you